look at this set of numbers twelve
sixteen twelve six eighteen two and four
let's find out the arithmetic mean of
these numbers first we know that it
equals the sum of values divided by the
number of values the sum of values would
be 12 plus 16 plus 12 plus 6 plus 18
plus 2 plus 4 and there are 1 2 3 4 5 6
& 7 7 values we divide this sum by 7 12
plus 16 is 28 28 plus 12 is 40 40 plus 6
is 46 46 plus 18 is 64 and 64 plus 6 is
70 so the mean would equal 70 divided by
7 that gives us 10 so the mean of these
seven numbers is 10 what we are
basically doing is finding an
approximate central value of a given set
of values so there are a couple of other
ways to find the central value to
understand them we first need to arrange
the values in ascending order from the
least number to the highest number 2 as
we can see is the least number we write
a 2 first the next higher number is 4 we
write a 4 next then 6 it is always a
good idea to mark the numbers you have
written with a pencil if the list is
huge there is a chance that you might
miss out a few numbers so 6 would come
next the next highest number after 6 is
12 and it occurs twice so we write 12
and 12 here then 16 then 18 we write 16
and 18 and that completes our list make
sure you have covered all values
arranging it in an ascending order gives
us something called the median the
median is the middle value of the list
when it's arranged in ascending order
there are seven values we have here and
we can see that 12 is the middle value
so the median of this set of values is
12
the median is just another way to
measure the central tendency so the mean
is the average and the median is the
middle value but only after we have
arranged the terms in ascending order
and the third concept is that of a mode
it is the value that occurs more
frequently in our list we can see that
12 occurs twice and all other numbers
occur just once so the mode of this set
of values is 12 why do we have three
concepts to know the central tendency
isn't one enough what are the
applications of each all these questions
will be answered in the coming videos
you